Okay.
So that's the coat of many colors.
So it's an estimation of what Joseph is
like and what we're seeing with all of
these patriarchal figures is the
continual realization of the ideal person,
right?
You could think about it as success
of approximations of the ideal person.
And the story is exploring all
sorts of different possibilities,
including ones that are very violent
and catastrophic and malevolent.
It's,
it's,
it's trying to cover the entire territory
and to focus in on what's the proper
way through the maze,
the maze of life,
the labyrinth.
And the hint here is that while
you should be multidimensional,
these are the generations of Jacob.
Joseph being 17 years old was feeding
the flock with his brother and allowed,
was with the sons of Bilhah
and with the sons of Zilpah,
his father's wives.
And Joseph brought unto his
father they're evil report.
Well,
we already know that Joseph has Jacob's
favorite and so that doesn't make him
very popular among his brothers.
He's younger.
And now we also find out that
he's being set up more or less,
as you might say,
a snitch,
because that's what this phrase means
is that he goes out and watch us,
his older brothers.
And if they do something
they shouldn't do that.
He comes trotting back
to Jacob and reports,
well that's not going to make you popular.
So,
and you would say,
well,
is that Joseph's problem
or Jacob's problem.
And I would say,
and this is something I learned
from reading dealing too,
is that that's a conspiratorial problem,
right?
Is it's the parents at fault,
but so is the child who agrees to do that.
They've got a little cabal
going and you might say,
well,
it's only the parents' fault,
but the sun will be taking advantage
of every advantage that offers him.
Because he could say no to.
I won't do that.
So anyways,
so Joseph is the favorite.
He's a bit of a teacher's pet.
That's what it looks like.
Now,
Israel loved Joseph more than all his
colors because he was the son of his old
age and he made him a coat of many colors.
And when his brethren saw that their
father loved him more than all his
brothers,
they hated him and could not
speak peaceably unto him.
So let's say you have a child or number
of children and one of them is your
favorite.
How should you treat that child?
Well,
it isn't obvious that you do them any
favors by overtly making them be your
favorite,
right?
I mean,
first of all,
maybe you don't challenge
them as much as you should.
And second of all,
you definitely set up a cane,
enable like scenario in
the household and that,
or maybe it's an edible situation too
because you happen to love your child more
than you love your,
your spouse,
which is,
that's not a recipe for familial harmony.
So it's,
it seems to be a bad idea.
Okay.
So now we have two reasons that Joseph
is not liked by his brothers is,
one is,
well he's a bit of a rat Fink
and the other is that he's the,
he's the favorite and he's playing that
to the hilt by the looks of things.
And when his brethren saw
that their father loved him
more than all his brethren
and all his brothers,
and they hated him and could
not speak peaceably unto him,
okay.
And Joseph dreamed a dream and he told
it to his brethren and they hated him.
The more.